so talk shout take command who is that B
famous B Russell in 41 you called for a
large scale March the time has come for
another no
bad I can handle all the grub work rally
the young we are going to put together
the largest peaceful protest made up of
angelic troublemakers such as
yourselves my friend Dr Martin with the
King will be joining us how many bodies
do it take to surround the White House
how
many sorry I thought that was a setup
for a joke you literally want me to find
out when it comes to the old G I'm
considered a pariah every person at this
table will be in the line of fire
because of him how's everyone so
obsessed with what I'm doing and with
whom how can you preach salvation and
not want to save yourself every day we
surrender that which makes us different
I can't surrender my differences the
world won't let me the day of your March
the entire DC police force has been
mobilized what they really want to
destroy is All of Us coming together and
demanding this country
change I remember saying that this
rusting fell is a little crazy only
later did I fully comprehend that a
little didn't even come
close we intend to go there not by the
thousands but by the hundreds of
thousands yes we are committed to
altering the trajectory of this country
towards Freedom that's what's on the
line nothing
less Lord I hope and pray they come
[Music]
today
of